is the commissions of both the House of
Commons and Lords have decided that Tick
Tock will be blocked from all
parliamentary devices and The Wider
parliamentary Network cyber security is
a top priority for Parliament however we
do not comment on specific details of
our cyber or physical security controls
policies or incidents so that's the
breaking news we understand that
Scottish Parliament have followed suit
as well making their own announcement
this afternoon here with me in the
studio following events former senior at
military intelligence and security
officer Philip Ingram and Philip you'll
have been watching the evidence from The
Tick Tock CEO there this is a really big
issue in the U.S at the moment and the
Department of Justice investigating the
app spying
on U.S journalists and now the wider
question is being asked about data
security cyber security of Americans who
use tick tock on their phone I mean some
of the statistics there's 150 million
users in the US there are five million
U.S businesses on this platform if you
want to make a surveillance device and
you want to get it out there to capture
Big Data you want to make it something
goes viral like Tick Tock has done
um and if you want to make it free well
nothing's free something has to be the
commodity and that Commodities the data
the data of the users and the data that
could be on the devices that those users
are accessing the app through and that's
where the real concern comes in and it's
interesting as you look at more and more
organizations Banning it's like
Parliament has just done Donald Trump
had originally banned it as soon as Joe
Biden came in and the current U.S
president
um he took that ban away he's now
looking at bringing the band back in
again after they look more and more into
the data security behind it and we've
seen the same through UK Parliament and
also were so the more people look at
this the more it goes back to you know
the the tick tock CEO Shu Chu um giving
evidence in the states at the moment has
turned around said that they don't
um gather data on citizens and give that
to the Chinese will the parent company
bite dance when it was called out a
couple of years ago actually then
admitted it did get that data and it
tracks some U.S journalists and an
undisclosed number of other individuals
which it didn't give any detail behind
so there is this um historical bit of
work they haven't quite told the truth
before yeah there was a bit of back and
forth there between the congresswoman
and The Tick Tock CEO she too about what
happens to that data she mentioned as
you said the fact that the Department of
Justice is already investigating
um surveillance of U.S journalists
through the app and the big issue of
course is the fact that Tick Tock is
Chinese owned and but the tick tock CEO
they were saying look we're not under
the control or manipulation of the
Chinese government and he was reminded
that he was talking on oath and you know
to say Miss Truth it would be a federal
crime but just remind us you mentioned
there about the data Gathering and
without being flipping here a lot of
people are all watching at home would be
like I've got tick tock on my phone he
shares videos what kind of harmful data
or vulnerable data are they getting from
us you know doing a dance to a Beyonce
song well it's not just necessarily
accessing the the dance to the Beyonce
song it's accessing your location it's
accessing your contacts it can access
your camera because you've given up
permission to it can access your
microphone because you're gonna have
permission to
um there are some apps that are out
there there is code that can be put in
them so that you can turn these things
on even if you've turned your phone off
um the terms and conditions that are in
um Tick Tock are very Bland you could
interpret them anyway so in effect
you're giving up permission to access
anything that is on your device your
personal photographs your your posts
that you're putting up on other
platforms that may just be there for or
friends family and you think you've
locked on so it's right for harvesting
it's harvesting everything that's the
real danger that is behind this
um and whilst he was saying that the
data has been held in the continental
United States where's the backup data
being held how is it transmitted to
their Tick Tock targets videos to those
that are using it and that feed
um the same sort of subject areas that
they're looking at how's it doing that
because there's algorithms going behind
us analyzing all of the data and all the
interactions that you're doing and when
you're getting it permission to do that
when you accept terms and conditions and
then it's targeting other things that it
thinks that you want to see embeds
advertising within that and that's how
it gets its Revenue it's it can be very
very manipulative